we are creating
an architecture of surveillance that is
so good that if it gets taken over by a
bad government we are in serious trouble
because it will be impossible to resist
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
frances foster i'm constantine kissin
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people a brilliant guest we have for you
today she's an associate professor at
oxford university and the author of
privacy is power a brilliant book
carissa velas welcome to trigonometry
thank you so much for having me it is
great to have you on the show listen
before we get into talking about the
subject you cover in your brilliant book
uh just tell everybody a little bit
about who are you how are you where you
are what has been the journey that leads
you here to be sitting here talking to
us
i'm a philosopher uh because i was never
good enough at jobs to be a comedian
although i would love to be a comedian
but you know second best is philosopher
and i studied philosophy as a ba ema and
then phd
i was writing my dissertation on
something related to ethics but very
different and then i started researching
the history of my family my family were
spanish
refugees in mexico from from the spanish
civil war and they had never talked
about the war it was a very sensitive
topic and i went into the archives and
uncovered so much about them that time
told us and it made me wonder whether i
had a right to know these things that
they hadn't told us whether i had a
right to tell my family or maybe even
publish about it because it was so
interesting
and being a philosopher i looked into
the philosophy of privacy and realized
there was a huge gap in the literature
there was very little written about it
the letter that there was was kind of
outdated and and we
didn't really address the questions that
i was asking myself and then that same
summer snowden came up with his
revelations that we were being
surveilled at a mass scale and i thought
i just i need to change the topic of my
dissertation so i did and i started
researching about privacy which
eventually led me to to write this book
privacy is power and there's so many
fascinating insights in in your book i'm
actually going to quote you and my book
because
you talk about some stuff that's really
not get doesn't get talked about much at
all and we'll get into some of that what
were some of the
things that shocked you or surprised you
the most when you were doing this
research and talking about privacy
it was shock after shock after shock
because i think one of the interesting
things about studying data is that it's
so abstract that we're just not made to
understand that kind of thing our
psychology just doesn't work that way so
even now when i read things that i have
written myself you know i have
researched and written and i know them
by heart i still get shocked because
that it just does it's so invisible so
i'll give you a few examples
actually the most shocking example and
most concerning example i decided not to
publish it because i think it's so
dangerous that anyone could misuse it
and you know i wouldn't want to
facilitate that but some examples of
just corporate surveillance and your
phone at night is sending information
that it has collected throughout the day
and it sends us at night so you don't
notice that your battery is draining
because you know people typically
connect it at night and charge it charge
their phones at night
and
companies are tracking very sensitive
things like whether you sleep okay at
night or not at what time do you wake up
with whom do you sleep which can tell
people you know who is your partner but
also things like whether you're having
an affair
um if you have a smart car it's tracking
not only where you go and how fast you
drive and how well you drive but things
like um the music you listen to and what
that tells about your mood but also the
seats in your car is measuring your
weight and you know potentially selling
that information to insurance companies
who might want to know you know if
you're getting a bit too slim or a bit
too fat um
and
they know things about your health
records your educational records your
purchasing power your browsing history
and people search
the things that they care most about the
things that worry them their diseases
and whether they can you know pay their
their loan and so it's very very
sensitive it's just shock after shock
after shock
and garissa why is this a problem well
you know because people go well so what
all they're doing is collecting data
what does it matter
it matters because privacy is power
because data whoever has the data in the
digital age will have the power because
data gives not only the possibility of
selling that data which gives them money
which already makes them very powerful
but it gives them the possibility to try
to predict what you're going to do next
and try to influence that and change
that
and that is incredibly attractive for
companies but also for governments
and it's something that we we haven't
been focusing on enough
i was reading this book by bertrand
russell the philosopher called power and
he argues that we should think about
power as something like energy in that
it can transform itself from one thing
into another so if you have enough
economic power then you can buy votes or
buy politicians if you have enough
political power you can buy military or
get military power and so on and there's
this
really important kind of power in the
digital age having to do
with forecasting and prediction
that has always been there in a way
we've always known that the more
knowledge you have on somebody the more
power you have over them but we have
never had this capability of amassing so
much data and of analyzing it so it
matters because the more others know
about you the more you're vulnerable to
them in all sorts of ways that are
invisible to you but you might get
discriminated against for a job or a
loan application or an apartment um you
might get extorted you your identity can
be stolen and your democracy can be
stolen as well because it influences how
we relate to one another as citizens
and in your book you use many many
examples the one that i found
particularly powerful was the example of
the man in virginia
oh yeah
so i have a friend who was training at
the time to be a data analyst and and he
was telling me like what it's like to go
through that training and one of the
exercises that that they had to do is
just pick a random person anywhere in
the world and just research anything and
everything you can about them so this
random data analyst um picked this
random guy in virginia and he learned
everything about him so if i remember
correctly this was a man who who had
diabetes who was having an affair and he
knew what kind of car that he drove
what job he had who were their friends
who were the family
and this person had no idea that
somebody was completely taking off his
clothes metaphorically online
and you know i think one of the concerns
that people
would have had in the past is that the
government is watching you right the
government is surveilling you and and
they as we now know as you say from
edward snowden that were right to have
that concern but i think
am i right in thinking that now actually
the biggest threats in terms of our
privacy in terms of being watched in
terms of being controlled in terms of
people kind of under tracking us and
trying to influence and shape our
behavior is not necessarily the
government itself it's actually
corporations big tech people who want to
sell you ship basically
yeah that's partly right because most of
data is actually collected by companies
and only then do governments make a copy
of the data but it's really the
companies that are best best and have
more resources to collect data and they
have many reasons to use that data
against you like i mentioned that you
can you can be discriminated against in
all kinds of settings so it's
essentially they're undermining equality
and equality of opportunity you are not
being treated as as
an equal citizen you are being treated
on the basis of your data but at the
same time we shouldn't forget government
because
it almost makes no sense to separate the
corporate surveillance from the
government surveillance right now um
because they they share data all the
time so every time a company
collects data that data is can
potentially um go to the government and
the government very often just makes a
copy of the data immediately
but also every time the government
collects data that data also ends up in
the hands of corporations so we've seen
this in the coroner virus pandemic in in
the uk
and the nhs has given data to palantir
this very shady and data company that
was partly funded by the cia and they
gave data not only
that you know might be more kind of i
don't know understandable about people's
health to fight the coroner's pandemic
but they also got data for example about
people's criminal records and there was
no explanation as to why exactly this
company needed that data and and what
was going to happen to that data so the
flow of information goes both ways to
such a large extent that it almost makes
no sense to to differentiate between
them
and the other thing that people often
say uh when i've talked to people about
this is it's always the same thing which
is well i'm not doing anything wrong i
don't care uh what what what should i
worry about what what do you say to
people who think about these things that
way
well there are at least two responses
one is you actually do care because
nobody wants to have their identity
stolen that takes you know that's a
hassle it can actually get you to jail
without having done anything wrong
whatsoever because somebody else uses
your name to commit crimes in your name
um but also you are vulnerable in all
sorts of ways even if you do nothing
wrong so for instance
maybe you have a disease or maybe you
have a disease that you don't know about
and that a company wants to pick up on
before even you do and then discriminate
against you next time you ask for a loan
or a job or something like that and so
there are all kinds of reasons why our
privacy is important even if we do
nothing wrong but furthermore even if
you didn't care about yourself you just
said you know i'm a masochist i want to
be stolen and i want to be exposed and
extorted i'm fine with that it's just an
interesting experience and you should
protect your privacy because privacy is
actually a collective thing this
narrative that the tech companies have
sold us that privacy is just a personal
preference is something individual and
if you're not shy and you're not a
criminal then you have no reason and to
protect your privacy is totally mis
misguided
because when when you expose yourself
you expose others
so every time you share your location
you're sharing data about your neighbors
and your co-workers every time you share
data about your genetics you're sharing
data not only about your siblings and
parents and kids and cousins but very
distant kin that can suffer really bad
consequences like being deported or
being denied health insurance or or life
insurance um
even if they didn't do the test
themselves and you're not you don't know
that you're actually um kin and you've
never met that person
and in the same way um
society benefits from people
protecting their data so one example is
cambridge analytica only 270 000 people
gave their data to the firm and with
that data the political firm managed to
get their hands on the data of 87
million people who were the friends of
these original 270 000 people but who
didn't consent to anything and then with
that data the the company made a tool
that was
supposed to profile voters around the
world so that's a very clear case of how
those persons didn't have the moral
authority to share their data because
that had consequences for everyone else
and i think people often massively
underestimate the predictive ability of
individual bits of information so i
remember during the cambridge analytica
thing there was a website where you
could see
what their website would essentially
predict about you uh and when i did it i
lit my facebook profile literally just
had like my music and movie preferences
on it at the time
and when i put that in it was like
terrifyingly accurate about my political
views about all sorts of other things
just based on the movies and the music
that i i had happened to enter um and
and this is one of the things i think
that's massively under appreciated just
how much you can predict about a person
with often things that aren't even
necessarily relevant to the thing that
you're predicting like you know we had
dr pipper malngram on the show talking
about this how people who eat
blueberries are more likely to be
conservative or whatever like stuff that
you would never think
is actually predictive is can be used
for that effect right exactly that's
super important when people think that
they're sharing their data they think
about the data that they think they're
sharing and then they say you know what
do i care if facebook knows my music
preference but what we don't imagine is
that being used to calculate our sex
sexual orientation or iq and that's
being used by companies when we ask for
a job or something so one example was
it turns out that people who like a
facebook page of curly fries have a very
high iq
and of course when you like a facebook
page for curly fries it's never going to
cross your mind that that's going to be
used to calculate your iq and the
hypothesis is that this facebook page is
probably created by somebody very smart
very smart people tend to have friends
who are also very smart and that's
probably the explanation but that's one
of the problems with algorithms that
they always work on correlations not
causation and there's no way of knowing
what they're going to correlate so
the concept of informed consent doesn't
even make sense with data because you
don't know what you're consenting to
because you don't know what kinds of
inferences are going to be made with
that data in the future
i bet you like curly fry's page mate
yeah i do actually i always thought i
was very intelligent as a result
carissa
why is it
so we've seen what's happening we've
seen that there's been a massive data
grab by these companies why haven't laws
been put in place to stop this kind of
behavior
it's it's it's a good question and it's
complicated the first reason was because
governments after 9 11 was were very
scared about what happened they wanted
to prevent it at all costs and it was
intuitive to think that the more data
they had on people the more they could
do something about it and keep people
safe now it just turns out that big data
is not the kind of analysis that is good
for preventing terrorism big data is
fantastic at knowing what you're going
to buy tomorrow because we have data
from billions of people who buy things
every single day but terrorism will
always be a very unusual event and that
makes it very hard to understand for big
data so the first reason was because
governments thought they had an interest
in keeping the data now you know 20
years have passed
since then and i think governments are
are slowly learning that having all that
data stashed away is a national security
danger so i think that's going to
motivate motivate them to change the law
but another reason why laws haven't been
put in place is because data is very
hard to police so actually the gdpr is
quite good it's not perfect it has a lot
of flaws but it was a very important
step in the right direction but it's
just impossible to police because
everybody's breaking the law all the
time many times citizens can't even
denounce it because we don't even know
what's going on it's not like we can see
your data being stolen and it hurts
right or you can't breathe or something
like that it's not tangible so how are
you going to complain if you don't even
know that it's happening so the
implementation of the gdpr is facing a
lot of difficulties they're underfunded
as well the data protection agencies and
we're dealing with giants um and the
third reason why we don't have more
strict laws is you know there's a lot of
money involved and there are a lot of
interest and these companies lobby
really hard and they pay more than any
other company in the world um to
pressure politicians so it's a big
challenge but i am cautiously optimistic
that eventually we're gonna
regulate it because this is just
unsustainable it's a ticking bomb
and you say it's a ticking bomb
have things got worse under covid
because yeah
i knew what the answer was can you
explain why though carissa
yeah so one reason is that we've just
been forced to use
digital stuff more and more and more
and you know one advantage is that the
narrative that you know we can always
opt out and it's up to us kind of has
has
totally disintegrated right it's obvious
to everyone that you can't opt out if
you want to be a participant in society
there's no way to opt out of um
interacting with the digital
but we have been forced to to use it a
lot more and therefore a lot more data
is being collected also times of crisis
are notoriously
uh dangerous for civil liberties these
are times in which governments
very often pass laws and measures that
wouldn't be accepted in in other
circumstances and so in this case i
think there was a
well-intentioned
idea that the more data we have the more
we can have tools to stop covid it turns
out that that actually hasn't been the
case once again that ai hasn't been
helpful to stop coving and you know the
tracking applications haven't been the
most important aspect of fighting kobit
um but the measures are there and they
don't have a sunset clause so we don't
know when they end and what happens to
all that data that has been collected
and
one thing the government has done and
nobody's talking about this but i think
that this is absolutely major they've
got rid of cash can you explain why that
is such a disastrous thing for our
society possibly especially for me
because i don't want to pay tax but
that's
that's beside the point
which cost you from again
anyway
people are not talking about that enough
but cash is very important because it's
the only way in which citizens can buy
things without being tracked
and
um
of course you know if if we don't have a
society in which we are interacting with
each other we're just interacting
through online we're all using credit
cards we're all using paypal and that
gets tracked really easily and so
there's no way to buy things um
or or services you know that hasn't been
tracked and you can say well but that's
great because that fights crime right
and yes it fights crime it can be
helpful to fight crime but it also does
away with certain kinds of privacy that
are really important so here are a few
examples
paying a lawyer that's very kind of
revealing about what you're interested
in or what you might be worried about
paying for a psychiatrist or a
psychologist or other kinds of
support
and
buying books so
it's
books are very revealing again of what
you're interested in and what you're
worried about and
a lot of people i think are very
complacent because they think well we
live in a democracy our government is
not out to get me you know for what i
read and fair enough
but right now the taliban have gotten a
hold of u.s biometric systems
and
the point is that
we are creating
an architecture of surveillance that is
so good that if it gets taken over by a
bad government we are in serious trouble
because it will be impossible to resist
and even if i mean i think it's very
yeah complacent to think that our
government would always be benevolent
and democratic because
the best predictor that something will
happen in the future is if it's happened
in the past and it's happened in the
past that we don't have the best
government possible
and but even if you thought okay no this
country is amazing and it's always going
to have the right government can you be
sure that in 10 years time we're not
going to be invaded by another
government by china by russia i don't
know by somebody else um i think that
you have to be really confident in your
like soothing abilities to not be scared
about
having this architecture of surveillance
and the thing that i've been worried
about chris throughout this entire
pandemic is the government has tried to
introduce mass surveillance in the form
of the vaccine passports and people have
been so complacent they've been like
they've just been well what's the
problem
yeah i think it's really hard to be
critical in times of crisis because the
kind of opposition you face is oh well
yeah we need to save lives aren't you in
favor of that and of course everybody
wants to save lives and so we don't want
to be a problem but i think we have to
um question not only whether we need
vaccine passports but even if we
accepted them
in what format do we need them so one
question is
why do they have to be digital
we've we've worked very well in the past
with paper and passports and paper
certificates of different kinds the
problem with digital is that it can be
hacked it collects a lot of data
and
there's just
no justification people just assume
today that it has to be digital
are you know coming back just a little
bit to what you were talking about in
terms of the possibility of the data
being used by foreign actors i mean you
don't even necessarily have to be
invaded by china the chinese could just
hack the database and then
influence elections cause civil unrest
you know undermine uh you know democracy
in one way or another and you know we
saw in 2016 the allegations about russia
you know where i'm from you know causing
brexit getting trump elected it doesn't
look like that that was what happened
based on on some of the things we've
seen but it's certainly not impossible
right
and vice versa you could see
powerful western actors the united
states and britain influence election
influencing elections in other countries
using exactly the same technology
so
but before you know what actually before
we talk about that let me ask you the
counter argument which is increasingly
my job on this show
a lot of people might say well i hear
what you're saying but on the other hand
doesn't big data have huge potential
for identifying disease in people who
don't even know they have it and
therefore getting treatment ahead of
time you know if it turns out that you
know buying more of something means
you've got cancer shouldn't don't we
want to know that so we can stop people
from dying of cancer don't we want to
prevent certain things from
escalating that we could we could
prevent surely those are all good things
carissa
absolutely and i have a whole section in
the book about medicine because it's
such an important point and medicine is
such a good example of that and the
first thing to say is that it has a lot
of potential but we shouldn't like
give up all our data and our civil
liberties for something that has
potential
we have to have some evidence that it's
actually going to work right having
potential is like really dreamy and i'm
fantastic and promising but that's not
enough and it's been very very
disappointing how millions and millions
and millions of pounds have gone into ai
tools in during the covid pandemic and
the two major studies that have
researched this claim that
out of the hundreds of tools that have
been developed not one of them is
clinically viable
and that should make us think twice like
are we making the right decisions here
it's not only about privacy it's also
about resources are we are we putting
our resources in the right place but
let's say that you know it can work or
or like we should give it a shot or we
should research the devil is in the
details it's not that we shouldn't use
personal data at all we can use it and
especially for medicine if you go to
your doctor and you don't want to tell
them what's wrong with you they're not
going to be able to help you it's as
simple as that
but we don't need to buy and sell
personal data for that we don't need to
allow data brokers to know everything
about us we don't need to allow the
government to know anything everything
about us so there's a huge difference
between using personal data for things
that are important and
then having a market of personal data in
which anyone can buy it the highest
bidder gets it that's that's very
different and that's what we should
avoid
i mean people might give another example
of let's say
the the lending which you've referred to
a number of times already
you could say well they're able to make
better decisions i mean 2008 would
suggest otherwise but uh you know in the
past if you wanted to get a mortgage
you'd have to go to the bank and the guy
in the bank would have to make a
personal decision based on how you were
dressed and and whatever else now we
have all this data which is very good at
predicting whether you know you're going
to be able to repay your mortgage surely
that's a good thing because we're you
know this is the argument we're not
giving people debt they can't handle et
cetera et cetera
well it depends it has to be shown it's
not enough to just say this works i want
to see how it works and it hasn't been
shown that way so for instance you know
one argument is your banker might have
all kinds of prejudice they might be a
racist there might be a sexist that's
actually quite plausible and and even
likely
but it turns out that algorithms are
you've clearly met a lot of bankers
[Laughter]
no i actually haven't but um
you know it turns out that algorithms
are
are just as as biased or worse than
people so one thing that i have proposed
and again you know it depends on on on
the kinds of proxies that these
algorithms are using so in many cases
it's unfair that we are being treated as
a category and not as an individual so
say you live in a in a certain kind of
postcode in which people tend to not pay
their loans but you might be different
right you might you might be like super
serious and super um
good at paying back your loan and you're
not gonna get that loan because you know
your neighbors don't pay their loans or
your friends that face in on facebook
don't pay their loans and that seems
quite unfair so one of the things that i
have proposed recently in an article for
the harvard business review
is that we should only allow algorithms
that have really important decisions to
make like giving somebody a loan
and
to go out into the world if they have
passed a randomized control trial
so just like we do with medicines we
don't allow any medicine to just go in
the market without having been tested
not even in a crisis like the
coronavirus pandemic we had to make sure
that the vaccines were um safe and they
went randomized control trials well in
the same way an algorithm could go
through a randomized control trial and
we we could have an agency like in the
united states the fda the food and drugs
administration and to make sure that an
algorithm is safe
and to prove that it's actually making
better decisions on the back the banker
carissa isn't part of the problem here
that we have this new technology it's
brand new
we don't actually understand the full
ramifications of this technology
yeah so it's really reckless to just let
it lose into the world essentially we're
treating people as guinea pigs and
that's totally wrong and we used to do
it with medicine so when you went to the
doctor in the 1950s you could get um
sign up for an experiment without
knowing
and
after the the nuremberg code which is
like one of the most important medical
ethics codes we decided that we don't
experiment on people without their
consent so if you want to carry out
clinical experiments you get you inform
people about what you're doing you get
their consent and then you give them
some kind of compensation and we should
do the same thing and right now we're
not doing it we are being
guinea pigs all the time of algorithms
without even knowing it
and one of the things i found really
fascinating about your book and this is
the bit that i i mentioned i want to
reference in mind is the fact that
people often don't understand that
intentionality and malice and the
deliberate evil is actually completely
unnecessary for harm to be caused so the
collection of data today
completely innocently or indeed for
beneficial purposes will often end up
being useful to to people who do want to
use it for evil can you talk a little
bit about that
yeah that's really important to have in
mind because i don't think that you know
i
i think that most people in tech and
most people in finance and most people
um just have good intentions or at least
not bad intentions they just want to do
well in life they want to um innovate
and so on
but hannah aaron had this amazing term
called the banality of evil and the idea
is when we think of evil when we think
of the nazis we think of um the paradigm
of somebody like hitler who who you know
you imagine somebody who hates jews and
wants to hurt people and wants to kill
people and that's our paradigm of evil
but in fact most of the time evil gets
perpetrated by perfectly normal people
who are just bureaucrats and that's that
was her um conclusion with the eichmann
trial that this guy was just a
bureaucrat he wasn't a monster he was
just following orders he wasn't critical
and he was just a cog in the system
and it's really important that we we
don't become cogs in a system that
creates injustice and and that you know
erodes democracy and even creates evil
and
it's not enough for us to think of
ourselves as good people and have good
intentions and we need to be a lot
smarter than that and a lot more
critical to avoid evil and one of the
examples you give on that very issue
speaking of the nazis is the fact that
survival rates in different european
countries for jews were different
because they have they had different
practices of collecting data and those
that collected data by ethnicity which
may have been perfectly reasonable under
a legitimate democratic sensible
non-discriminatory government then fell
into the hands of people who wanted to
use it to discriminate to kill two
murder two
and that innocent collection of data led
to more people being killed because of
it right
yeah i think it's a perfect example to
show that personal data is a ticking
bomb and so the dutch had a very good
system of statistics they had a guy
called lens who was one of the pioneers
of statistics and he wanted to build a
system that followed people from cradle
to grave and in his senses there were a
lot of questions and there was data
collection about your religious
affiliation but also your ancestry and
things like where your grandparents
lived now in contrast in france they had
made a decision um since 1872 not to
collect that kind of data for privacy
reasons
and so when the nazis arrived to france
and asked you know where the jews they
said you know we have no idea how many
jews we have let alone where they live
so good luck with that and the nazis had
to depend on either jewish people um
turning themselves in or having
neighbors neighbors to turn them in
which was very inefficient and the
result is that in the netherlands the
nazis found and killed 73 of the jewish
population and in france 25 of the
jewish population and the difference is
hundreds of thousands of people and if
this has happened in europe already we
really have to
make sure that we don't make the same
mistake again there's a reason why
privacy is in the declaration of human
rights
and we have forgotten that lesson and we
we have to relearn it pretty quickly
before before something really bad
happens again and there's one story in
particular in the second world war that
i think is very illustrative
of what we need to avoid and that's um
because the nazis one of the first
things they did when they invaded cities
was go to the registry because that's
where the data was held there was a
resistance cell in amsterdam that wanted
to destroy the registry in 1943. so they
went into the building they sedated the
guards to spare their lives they set
fire to the records and they had a deal
with the fire department that they were
going to arrive late and that they were
going to use more water than necessary
to destroy as many records as possible
and unfortunately they were very
unsuccessful they only managed to
destroy about 15 percent of the records
they got caught and killed and the nazis
um found 70 000 jews in amsterdam and
the dutch had made two mistakes one they
had collected too much data that wasn't
necessary to have a functional society
and the second one is that they didn't
have an easy way to delete that data in
the event of an emergency and we are
making both of those mistakes at a grand
scale and that should make us think
twice
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website well if you do then easy
dns are the company for you easy dns is
the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be council culture d
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows a bit about
that so will you in a second easy dns
have rock-solid network infrastructure
and incredible customer support they're
in your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you'd know about that
move your domains and websites over to
easy dns right now all you've got to do
is head over to easydns.com forward
slash triggered and use our promo code
which is of course triggered as well and
you will get 50 off the initial purchase
sign up for their newsletter access of
easy that tells you everything you need
to know about technology privacy and
censorship
carissa what would you say to those
people who go look the cat's already out
of the bag there's nothing that we can
do these companies are so huge they're
so powerful they're so wealthy and we're
just nothing but a collection of
individuals
i would say that's a lack of historical
perspective we have had very powerful
companies in the past we've regulated
from you know railroads to cars
airplanes food drugs there's no reason
why we shouldn't be able to regulate
tech in fact tech is less complicated in
many ways than finance and we regulated
finance and furthermore
the united states for instance had to
face rockefeller on their own you know
france the uk they didn't care about
rockefeller but now there's so many
countries that want to regulate big tech
so yes they're very powerful but they're
not more powerful first than all the
collective users on which they depend
because they depend on our data and if
we rebel and don't give them our data or
obfuscate they're in trouble and second
they're not more powerful than the
collection of the uk the us canada and
south america um australia new zealand
europe japan
we can gang up
and
don't you think part of the problem is
as well is that people aren't getting
angry about this because a lot of the
time they don't really understand it
they don't understand that it's
happening to them first of all and also
they don't understand the long-term
implications of this data harvest
yeah that is true and that's a challenge
we have uh on the upside more and more
people i mean upside down side more and
more people are having bad experiences
online so in a survey i did with a
colleague chen brook
we found out that about 92 percent of
people have had some kind of bad
experience related to privacy online
sometimes it's about getting your credit
card number stolen sometimes it's about
being exposed on twitter sometimes it's
about you know having an ex-boyfriend um
track you or something like that and the
more we have bad experiences the more we
learn that actually privacy was
important after all and the more we get
angry that these companies are making us
vulnerable but you're right that we need
a lot more consciousness and in
particular we need to be much more aware
of the political implications of privacy
this is not an individual thing or it is
an individual thing but it's much more
than that
and
do you think that for instance when you
look at something like china that is a
warning for us all particularly in this
country
it's such a huge warning and it's such
an interesting case for so many reasons
but one reason is that you know they
claim that they are more ethical than we
are because we're doing the same thing
we're scoring people but we're just not
telling them and there's actually some
truth to that of course the the flip
side is that
we
have a lot more freedom and even if
you're being scored say as as a consumer
that's not going to impact whether you
get i don't know a place at a university
or or a job so we're much more
compartmentalized and that's part of
what makes a liberal society liberal and
instead of being a totalitarian
regime we have to make sure that we
don't walk into that system we have to
walk away from it and i i am very
worried that we're walking towards it
but now a really interesting
lesson from china is coming through
right now as we speak and that's that
one argument from the west
for not regulating data was that you
know we have to have as much data as
possible because look at china they're
collecting so much data and if we don't
collect enough data we will be at a
disadvantage and now it turns out that
china is passing one of the strictest
privacy laws in the world right now and
that's very interesting there's a lot of
speculation about why exactly are they
doing it they're hurting their stock and
so why exactly are they doing it
what reason i think it
may not be the only reason but one
really important reason is that they are
realizing
how dangerous it is to have so much
personal data um stored because it's a
national security danger and the west is
going to hack it sooner or later and
make a use of it so even even china is
regulating privacy like we really have
to get our act together quickly and how
close do you think we are to that kind
of dystopia karissa where
you know you go and get a loan and for
reasons unbeknownst to yourself you fail
it your credit rating is excellent you
know you've never been in debt you've
never defaulted on a payment yet because
you don't know that you have a you know
a genetic condition but a company does
you're not going to get the money
it's really hard to say
part of me thinks that that probably is
already happening but it's just very
hard to tell because everything's under
on underground and we can't see it so it
wouldn't surprise me that those things
are already happening but they just have
they just haven't come out to the light
and then depending on you know it's it's
hard to predict because if we get you
know one prime minister or another in a
few years it can really make a
difference and if the us you know gets a
different president
things can change so quickly uh for
better and for worse
yeah as we've seen in recent days uh uh
chris moving on a little bit i know that
you are an associate professor at the
institute for ethics and ai do you mind
if we talk a little bit about ai more
broadly
yeah sure
uh because i i remember i was listening
to elon musk a few a few weeks ago
talking about
he was asked a bunch of broad questions
but one of them was like what terrifies
you the most about the future and he was
saying it's ai and i i
i remember as growing up as a kid i
would read all the sci-fi the asimov and
the other stories a lot of which were
really exploring the implications of
having artificial intelligence and again
from a point of view not of some evil
plan to to control the world or whatever
but actually from a misplaced desire to
make things better where people would
give ai particular targets like let's
make human beings happy and before you
know it everyone is suddenly hooked up
to like a heroin drip because that's the
way you make people happy do you know
what i mean like should we be worried
about the the the
increasing influence of artificial
intelligence in our lives
yeah we should definitely be worried so
researching ai in the ethics of ai i
mean
one way to categorize it there are many
ways but one way is it broadly divides
into two the people who are really
worried about what is often called super
intelligence so the point at which um ai
becomes more intelligent than human
beings and then you know what are they
gonna do are they gonna get us hooked in
in heroin or
you know are they going to take over the
world and and so on and the people who
are worried about more short-term
problems like you know the the bias that
algorithms are instituting and so on i
think that those concerns about ai
taking over the world and and and what
are they gonna do are legitimate and we
should be thinking about it but my own
take is that the short term risks are
much more real tangible and they're just
like they're here they're here and they
can lead to a dystopia as bad as as you
know the ai that gets us hooked on
heroin so i think it would be as bad to
have this complacent attitude towards ai
and data and get into a totalitarian
regime that we can't resist because
we're being surveilled at the time than
you know the worry that robots might be
advanced enough to take over the world i
think we're we're pretty far from that
still give us give us some examples of
the of the smaller uh more short-term
stuff that you're concerned about with
artificial intelligence so one concern
is you know how is ai impacting things
like equality
and
so one thing our you know data and ai
are very closely related because the
most successful kind of ai at the moment
uses a lot of data and much of that is
personal data so it's hard to to
differentiate those two so one question
is you know is it okay for us not to be
treated as equals anymore but do we
treat it on the basis of our data and
what does that say about our society and
what implications that does that have
another very important um issue is bias
it's really hard to have an ai that is
not biased and it's really difficult to
identify the bias because you know when
we're not not aware of it and
there's a lot of evidence that shows
that ai is intensifying inequalities
that we're already there so you know
we've been you know as a society we've
been sexist for a long long time we're
pretty good at it um but ai can make us
even more sexist and without us
realizing in the same with racism
another issue that i'm worried about
sorry curious how can it do that how can
what are we going to design a robot that
is you know just goes around
wolf whistling
so there are many reasons why you can do
that but to give you a couple of
examples so a few years ago amazon used
an algorithm to um
they tested an algorithm to to try to
hire people and to filter candidates
because you know these big companies get
thousands and thousands and thousands of
applications
and they realized that the algorithm was
being sexist and the reason it was being
success is because in the past say in
the past 10 years amazon has tended to
favor men and so the kind of ideal
candidate for the algorithm is you know
the white guy
and if you know a cv had things like
somebody played in the women's soccer
team in high school say for as an
example the algorithm goes through the
successful candidates that have applied
to amazon in the past and nobody has
been in in a women's soccer game and so
it discriminates against that person for
no good reason
and we have to be really vigilant to to
to pick those up but another example is
there's a lot of sexism in medicine
and one of the reasons is that
most of the data we have
it comes from men so the the kind of the
paradigm of medicine is a white
male
and it turns out that women in many
cases are very different for different
things so for instance we our neural
pathways for processing pain are
different so it turns out that
painkillers are much more effective for
men
and so it's very easy to be sexist
without the intention of being sexist
it's not like you know we're trying to
design a sexist algorithm i think i
think we wouldn't be able to do it as
well if we tried it
um it's more that sexism is really baked
into how we have seen and experienced
the world and how we have hired and
treated people and because algorithms
work on historical data they tend to
reproduce that reality
that's so interesting
that that really is very interesting so
it's actually um it's actually
reproducing inequality that may not
actually exist in our minds today
i think very few people would choose
deliberately to discriminate against
women now in employment but the
algorithm is actually more sexist than
human beings potentially because it's
replicating data from 30 years ago that
that wow that really is interesting
isn't it and it's fascinating because it
shows us that it can actually
stop progress social progress and
political progress it's kind of um
regress in many in many ways and one of
the important functions of forgetting is
to progress because when you forget you
kind of let go of the past and you're
able to see the future with fresh eyes
and
you know in in the past we used to
forget all the time because our memories
are not perfect and
because recording was very effortful and
very expensive and because even when we
recorded say you put something on paper
when the paper didn't have acid it just
fell apart after a few years or it got
or there was a fire or a flood or
something but now the whole economy of
remembering and forgetting has has gone
upside down and now we're remembering
everything and just by default
collecting all the data we can and
storing it indefinitely
and that's really unwise and one reason
it's unwise is because it creates
societies that are very harsh when they
never forget but also because it it kind
of stops progress
and what about the other arguments sorry
francis just to finish on this very
point uh you know we talk about equality
but you might say from a kind of a
ruthless
russian mentality like mine
you could argue couldn't you that well
look these algorithms actually in many
cases i take the point about the the
disparity when it comes to sex but in
many cases they're making better
decisions in order so for example if you
are about to get a mortgage and you do
actually have a condition which means
you're highly likely to die in the next
five years shouldn't the the lender know
that before they give you a loan isn't
this just a way of keep making better
decisions and and being fairer because
we never really had equality like the
fact that if you don't pay uh back your
loans uh you shouldn't be treated as
equal by your bank to someone who does
do you see what i'm saying and the
algorithm is just amplifying the ability
to make accurate decisions some people
might argue
yeah so i'm reading an interesting book
at the moment called the tyranny of
merit and about the kinds of effects
that that it has in society to think
that you know people can just
um
are self-made and and we should judge
them accordingly and so i recommend that
but so the first thing to say is unless
we have randomized control trials that
show that these loans are actually
these algorithms are making better
decisions and getting
better returns
then you know we shouldn't believe it we
shouldn't believe it you know because
somebody says that we need randomized
controlled trials so that's the first
thing but secondly let's say that they
do work like that and let's say that
they are more effective we also have to
ask ourselves what kind of society do we
want to live in do we want to live in a
society in which because somebody gets
cancer they can't get alone um shouldn't
we have rules for that just not be like
a super harsh society in in which it's
really hard to thrive and and it becomes
kind of unlivable um or maybe you know
the government then should step in and
and give those loans to people who
might have more trouble or i don't know
we have to do something but we just
can't leave it to the market and think
that we're going to end up with this
wonderful fair society because we're not
and
moving forward if ai continues the way
it is doing and the way it's been
predicted to do that's going to have a
huge effect on the labor market isn't it
there's going to be significant slaves
of jobs that are just going to be
non-existent yeah there's a huge
controversy about it so some people
think that we're going to lose jobs and
we're never going to recover them other
people think that no no in the past this
has happened before and what happens is
that
people just change their jobs so when
technology gets
developed you know in farming you used
to take care of the cows and the horses
and now you take care of the tractors um
but some people think that because ai is
a different kind of technology in the
sense that we're trying for it to be
autonomous for it to not need input then
we are going to lose a lot of jobs then
there are people who think that actually
the best kind of ai works
in tandem with a human being ai is
really stupid on its own and if you've
had a conversation with siri or alexa
you will have noticed that and so many
people think that a more realistic
future is one in which we design a ai to
work with human beings and so yeah
that's that's a huge controversy and i
don't think you know i'm kind of neutral
about it i'm not sure i'm i'm not
confident enough to say yeah this will
go one way or the other
and one of the fascinating things that i
remember reading about recently is
the idea that in order to program ai to
make decisions for example driverless
cars
you're going to have to start to make
philosophical decisions about right and
wrong because let's say
a car that is not driven by a person but
it's driven by ai has to make a decision
do you crash into that car or do you
crash into this car because you you're
in the trap do you kill three people
there or do you kill one person there
like how how are we as humanity going to
resolve some of these moral moral
dilemmas that pop up
that's very difficult because on the one
hand you're right that we have to
make sure that we understand that
whenever we make a tool it has values
within it technology is not neutral and
we need to make sure that the right
values are in place so that we end up
with the kind of society that we want
but it turns out that ethics
arguably is something that you cannot
code into a computer so we're not
a normal human being doesn't act morally
in a way that can be coded easily into a
program
so there are many questions about how do
we deal with this one one way to deal
with it is
to
try to
teach ai as if we were teaching a small
child
so just like we teach ai to recognize
images by giving them say you know
millions of images of what is a dog and
what is a horse or whatever it is then
we should just give them millions of
cases of like what's the right thing to
do and what's the wrong thing to do now
other people say well but actually
people are really bad at being moral i
mean we see examples of immorality every
day all the time so maybe we you know we
should be more ambitious and actually
have an ai that is perfect not not just
like human level which is kind of
pathetic but that is actually virtuous
but then you know what kind of morality
do we do we accept so just to give an
example and something i've been thinking
about lately utilitarianism is a very
attractive moral philosophy for many
people the main idea of utilitarianism
is that you should maximize good
consequences you should maximize utility
how we cash out what utility depend you
know can vary but let's say we should
maximize well-being something like that
um and that sounds great and if you ever
meet a human utilitarian they're very
imperfect right because they think you
know they think they should do one thing
but it's very hard to do so for instance
they think that in order to maximize
well-being they should donate most of
their money to charity to to the poor
because that's gonna save lives and
that's gonna be better for the world but
when they have a family and they have a
kid it's really hard to do that and they
tend to prioritize their kid and you
know pay for college and the way they
explain that is i'm perfect you know i
should i know i shouldn't do that but i
have these like psychological um
constraints as a human being and i can't
help myself and i'm sorry about it and
you know for them that's a bad thing for
most other people it's kind of a relief
that you that they can't be able to
utilitarian because a true utilitarian
would always be strategic right so when
they are your friend they would only do
what maximizes well-being in the world
so they wouldn't favor you as a friend
and so i'm really relieved that i don't
have a friend who's a perfect
utilitarian but with ai we could turn it
into a perfect utility tyrant they don't
have those psychological constraints of
loving someone and being partial to
someone they could be a perfectly
utilitarian and that's kind of a
frightening um thought well you make it
more dystopian if you want because what
if the what if the truth is let's say
that uh we know statistically most
crimes in society are committed by a
small number of people uh many of them
have psychopathic disorders now what if
you were perfect ai utilitarian you
wanted to maximize well-being by i don't
know killing all those people right and
then you know you kill off two percent
of the population everybody else is
really happy
we get rid of boris johnson
yeah not to mention that you know the
easiest way to get rid of suffering is
just to
explode the world right
um
so yeah we have to make really really
sure that that we're um sensible in how
we program ai but i think at the moment
we should be focusing more on the on the
short term
um challenges on the than the long-term
ones because they're so urgent and it's
not going well no
um because it's also as well it opens a
whole pandora's box when it comes to
when it comes to the law
you know that you know for instance if a
driverless car malfunctions swerves into
the road kills six people
who onto the sidewalk or pavement i
should say you know who is ultimately
responsible for that
because it's not a human being you know
it's very simple if a human being does
that you go well the human being is in
charge of the technology but who is in
charge of that technology is it the
person programming the algorithm is it
the company you know was there a
malfunction was it the factory that
produced it doesn't this open a whole
minefield legally
it does it creates a lot of what's
called responsibility gaps in which
something goes terribly wrong and
everybody can say it wasn't me
uh and then we don't have incentives for
people to be careful with these things
because nobody pays the price and you
know that example with the car is a very
good one but there are so many others so
for instance a few years ago the
michigan unemployment agency used an
algorithm to detect fraud and it accused
thousands of people about 34 000 people
of
fraud falsely there were false
accusations so these were people who
were very
in a very
precarious situation already they take
their checks away and these are people
who lost their families they lost their
homes some of them committed suicide two
years later they realized that the
algorithm got it wrong 93 percent of the
time and who goes to jail no one because
nobody knows who's responsible was it
that you know they said the objectives
wrong was it that they hired the wrong
programmer which programmer because a
lot of people work that these algorithms
sometimes have millions of lines of code
and we so one of the things we need to
do is before an ai project starts we
have to design a chain of responsibility
and say exactly who's responsible of for
what before anything goes wrong so that
when things go wrong we can actually
know who to who to turn to
chris are you optimistic about the
future
i'm consciously optimistic i think it
can go both ways i think we're not 50 50
kind of place
but
i think we can turn things around and i
think we have done in the past so you
know one example i give in the book is
how we managed to recover the ozone
layer we were really
in danger and about to lose it and we
were using cfcs all over the place and
we we learned what we were doing we
regulated and now the ozone layer is
recovering and it's going to completely
recover in a few years so i think you
know i think it's possible i think we
can do it and my only hope is that we do
it in time before something really bad
happens i think eventually we're gonna
get it right the question is are we
gonna get it right now before something
really bad happens or are we gonna wait
for something like you know the nazis
using personal data for genocide in the
second world war um in the west
before we we get our act together
so so just before we finish so we're
talking and i'm miserable and a
pessimist so that's my position
so you talk about something really bad
happening you've given the example of
the nazis you know and a lot of people
will then say well look you know that
that's you know a once in a however many
generation thing could you give other
examples of what this type of misuse of
ai and algorithms could actually lead to
sure and so one example of personal data
being misused this was in the rwanda
genocide in 1994 as well and
personal data was misused in the second
world war with japanese people in the
united states um but also more recently
with algorithms the best example is
probably china using it against the
uyghurs and this is a minority in china
they are usually muslims and china has
developed algorithms to detect like
facial
features that are racial and they have
put these people in camps and and they
are
essentially persecuted and there's no
reason why that would couldn't happen in
the west another example is hong kong
hong kong was a very high-tech society
and that was
really in favor of democracy and
suddenly they realized that a lot of the
tech that they had developed was being
used against them when china got
exchanged their policies and wanted to
gain some control back so we had these
really impressive images of people
trying to take down cameras with facial
recognition in the street or people
queuing for blocks and blocks to buy
their subway ticket with cash instead of
all the machines that were much more
prevalent so that's one example in which
you know once things go wrong it's
really hard to go back so we have to
make sure that we have a system in place
as a buffer in case things go wrong
and i was going to say as well in terms
of personal uh things that we can do i
understand the regulatory stuff that
you're talking about
as as individuals what can we do to
protect ourselves
there's a lot we can do because these
companies depend on us on our data so
choose privacy friendly um
apps and devices don't ever buy a device
from a company like google that you know
earns their keep through through
collecting personal data instead of
using whatsapp you signal instead of
using google search use duckduckgo
instead of using gmail use something
like protonmail
uh instead of doing
using dropbox use jota cloud or there
are many alternatives out there protect
other people's privacy contact your
political representatives and tell them
that you care about this
um and in general let's kind of create a
culture of privacy and not a culture of
exposure
and don't use that facial recognition
software is that isn't that one that you
should absolutely avoid with the apps
yeah if you if you can definitely avoid
biometrics whenever possible
there we go uh charissa thank you so
much your book is called privacy's power
thanks for coming on where can people
find your other work online if they want
to follow you after this interview
um i rant on twitter a lot at carissa
veliz and they can find me on my website
it's justmyname.com
fantastic thank you so much we'll ask a
couple of questions for our local
supporters but for now uh thank you for
coming on and thank you guys for
watching at home we'll see you very soon
with another brilliant interview like
this one or raw show all of them go out
7 p.m uk time which is 2 p.m eastern
take care and see you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button so that you never miss
another fantastic episode and if you
believe that the work we do here at
trigonometry is important support us by
joining our locals community using the
link below